дорогі українські народи
шановні народні депутати
Дорогі високодостойні вельмишановні наші
гості Наші друзі надійні на яких ми дуже
покладаємося яким ми дуже вдячні
32 роки незалежності
10-й рік
російського вторгнень в чергової війни
Росії проти суверенної незалежної нашої
держави
півтори роки після початку
широкомасштабного вторгнення ця війна
назавжди ввійде в історію світу як війна
за незалежність України
і кожен з нас доволі знає як дорого
коштує наша Свобода
лише
работіна на цьому тижні лише курдюмовка
коли ми вчора втратили Сокола кожен день
Україна платить цю ціну
і ми точно знаємо що ми закарбували своє
місце на карті Ми ідемо до військової
Перемоги але до неї ще багато крові
багато поту багато сліз але в нас немає
жодного сумніву ми Здолаємо ворогу і
станеться це завдяки мужності єдиної
об'єднаної українського народу
сили іміці наших збройних сил
допомоги партнерів завдяки ідентичності
і мові завдяки духу і духовності завдяки
нашій вірі
вдумайтесь як вірив це левколо
Лук'яненко коли він був Новатор гіршому
становищі коли зустрічав сьогодні свій
день народження в камери смертників
приречений за страту але в нього жодного
Хвилини не було коли він мав сумніву як
ця Віра В'ячеслав Чорновіл інше батьки
засновники новітньої держави про яких
Сьогодні ми маємо згадати будучи в
безнадійний меншості вони жодної Хвилини
не мали сумніву в нашій перемозі
і тому ця ідея непоборна і для нас
критично важливі віри і впевненість Віра
є з такими людьми як українці і не може
не бути А для впевненості Нам потрібен
план чіткий план і цей план це є
членство України в Європейському Союзі і
запорукою сьогодні є присутні тут Наша
друзів і членства є в України в НАТО
Шкода що нема уряду це перший день
незалежності Коли уряд не присутній в
залі Верховної Ради Але я впевнений в
тому що наше головне свято ми
відсвятковуємо Ми переможемо ми будемо
членами ЄС сенато і слава Україні